well the clark county school district is
looking to stop the uptake in violence
on campus today superintendent dr jesus
jarrah addressed the concern modifying
the code of conduct in hopes that the
schools will be a safer place again for
both students and staff
this year has been a struggle the
struggle is real we live it every single
day side by side ccsd is partnering with
the clark county district attorney and
other community members sounding the
alarm to stop what they say is a major
concern across the school district
we've had over a thousand
logged citations and arrests from our
officers according to ccsd police 25
firearms were confiscated on campus
three thousand assaults and fights have
been reported since the beginning of
this school year and new this year
violence from parents parents coming
onto our campuses
committing acts of violence to students
to staff
and to each other we know that our kids
are struggling because of the stress
anxieties and isolation of the pandemic
but violence
is not
and will never be the answer as a
solution superintendent dr jesus jara is
increasing disciplinary actions for
students who violate their code of
conduct a physical altercation will
result to an infraction major fights and
gun possession will face the expulsion
review board ccsd will find ways to
re-engage students if expelled
cases like this also prompting ccsd to
enable a single entry point in schools
over the next couple of weeks the level
of violence
we are witnessing is much worse